estos sobrevivientes de complejo al sur
de acción hacen fila para recibir su
pequeña ración de alimentos repartidas
con dificultad por las organizaciones
humanitarias que buscan atender los
afectados por el terremoto
mientras que en la localidad de nan
consell en las montañas del sur del país
no lejos del epicentro del sismo los
hombres se reúnen para vender lo que
quedó de su ganado buscan obtener algo
de dinero para alimentar a sus hijos o
pagar los funerales de los miembros
fallecidos de su familia
mi casa fue destruida por el terremoto
varios miembros de mi familia murieron
tenía 13 cabras 11 murieron me quedan
dos mil su magia la vine al mercado para
ver si puedo vender las dos que quedan
no tenemos nada necesitamos ayuda
en haití el país más pobre de américa es
además uno con los niveles más altos de
inseguridad alimentaria en el mundo el
terremoto de magnitud 7.2 del 14 de
agosto agravó aún más la situación
devastando cultivos contaminando fuentes
de agua potable y destruyendo días que
dejaron aislados a miles de damnificados
según el programa mundial de alimentos
más de 215 mil personas necesitan una
asistencia alimentaria urgente sobre
todo en los tres departamentos más
afectados junto con dons y nippes hasta
los años 80 haití fue autosuficiente
pero la isla comenzó a flexibilizar las
restricciones a la importación de
productos básicos y bajo los aranceles
importando los excedentes de cultivos
estadounidenses una decisión que terminó
por destruir su economía arrocera además
el cambio climático ha golpeado la isla
que es vulnerable a sequías y huracanes
cada vez más extremos